I Married An Athlete yeah you did marry
an a hockey player a hockey player wow
how'd you meet him
um
through through that guy right there for
your bass player yeah no kidding what
you knew this hockey dude
uh he um I met him through a mutual
friend of ours yeah and he wanted to
meet Carrie behind stage of the Opry and
there we go again I didn't allow it I
was like I don't move I don't know who
he is whatever so he didn't meet her for
about a year so he kept he kept trying
and then had a meet and greet
persistence there's a motivated guy
isn't it but aren't you on guard about
stuff like that Carrie when someone says
well he saw me on TV and he wants to
meet me so he's just into my physical
appearance he doesn't know anything
about me you might have to be completely
leery of that right yes um I feel like
I've always kind of been I'm a skeptic
anyway and I feel like I'm I've got
walls up to to start with so the walls
are already up and then the person has
to get get through those Carrie is it
hard to be married to you because you're
a superstar you really I mean your
career is through the roof I mean
the the you know he was an elite athlete
he made his he worked hard at what he
did for you know 20 years he was playing
I was touring right it was craziness
when we were both doing what we do and
um well he played for Ottawa Senators in
the beginning in the Nashville Predators
oh no kidding he was he was blessed to
be traded to Nashville out of all the
places he could have been traded to that
is a tough sport I mean it is a tough I
think that's the most difficult YouTube
Mike Fisher hockey fights and then
you'll you'll see why he's secure he's a
fighter huh Mike Fisher hockey he's not
afraid to throw down how long did you
know him before you got married to him
um a little over a year that's it yeah
not maybe a year and a half well you
were really smitten with this week we
met in October and then we talked on the
phone for a few months before we went on
on our first date that's the move with
Carrie Underwood you know you're not too
rushing into it let's talk on the phone
I really want to get to know you that's
the secret we didn't have a choice right
now but it was good it kind of laid some
foundation and if you're just talking on
the phone you gotta which neither one of
us are talkers like it's it's we are
very comfortable with silence and I'm
comfortable in life with silence where'd
you go on your first date with this guy
I need to know it was New Year's Eve and
uh there was a teen party and I actually
invited myself to the team party he
moved slow
are these guys very slow and I was like
you know New Year's Eve's coming up are
you doing anything he's like there's a
team party and I said do you need a date
these hockey players must have gone
berserk when he shows up with Carrie
Underwood I mean they knew we'd been
chanting oh yeah yeah and that was the
first kiss on midnight on New Year's Eve
wow look at this that's romantic that is
romantic